I had baby fever but I didn't know that
like I really like neither the
thermometer but it was you know just
like I thought about it but I didn't
really know that it could actually
happen okay
so how did we were you secretly pregnant
at the time no I was pregnant okay so
how did we get here we're after that
where you like you know what why not you
said you love to practice there we
definitely we always love to practice
and we actually weren't practicing very
much that one so I don't understand we
keep trying to like this might be a
miracle how are you feeling I'm feeling
good
third time is definitely harder I think
just the older you get a little bit
harder yeah but the kids are so excited
so that's what makes it so much fun like
because they're only 14 months apart so
they didn't get to experience the
excitement of each other but when I told
them that we were having a baby like I
know that they'll remember that for the
rest of their lives
yeah they're five and six fights and
what are they most excited about with
having a baby sister they're most
excited about doing learning how to do
the swaddle Maxwell my daughter is just
so happy that it's a girl so I don't
know they asked me of the craziest
questions that I can't say on how did
this happen mommy where did the baby go
I have a the baby come yeah you know um
like where does the milk come from I
don't understand when I got those
questions I would just say look over
here what's happening over here I think
I'm a little bit too honest and Erik's
like I don't think we need to give out
all that information so I can fine yeah
so I like scaring our kids I think
biology 101 yeah how are Eric and ace
bonding now that they are going to be
officially outnumbered ace and Eric have
a very special relationship there Eric's
not with me today because he stayed home
with his ace was performing
assembly today so I had to miss out on
that but he knows that I was there in
spirit and I saw the video already and
cried yeah but they're you know they're
always bonding they're going they're
kicking the soccer ball hitting the
baseball yeah so you know everybody's
always like are they gonna feel left out
I don't think so they they have each
other
and Eric and I hope I think that we do a
pretty good job at balancing top
[Music]